SCIUTTO.LD. I'M JIM
WILLIAMS ASEADED THER ERS ANEN
AND KATE, F I COULD
YOU.
S SPANF THE LONGEST SE CERTAINL
HISTOROR 7AR
CELEBREDHI CE ACROSS SHE
UN
THAT SHE WOULD LEAF THLIFE
SEULD GIAYHAD
U AL
MY WHOLE LIFE,THT BENG OR LL BE
TOSERVICE AN
GRE IMPER TH WE A
BUT I SHALL NOVET  RE
OW SUPPORT WILL BEIL ME TO MAKE
R PLATINUM NG  I19ME OEFN
H WHEN STALKED ABOUTIN
PROMISE .
LL U THROUGH, SHE DID,T SHE.
>>epIDIT IS SUCH ASPEECHD LEASET
LLLE
DIR RVAN A HAS BEEN.
HER REIGNHE'STHOUGHT OF SERVICR
SHE IS OUT
CE, AND THAT WAS A E MADE WHEN .
SHE WAS BORN19 IT THROUGHOUT A .
SHE  THE LONGEST RINRCRY ANDWE E
AG
YESTERY UEEEELIZABETH
TRUSS AND SAYINGOORI
VE BINDO
AN
EDIBLE TESTAMENT TR  OF WILL.
>>NNA, YOU WERE AT BUCKINGHA
PALACE.
FOR THWH BG US, CAN YOU BRING UT
OUND, NOT  AT TH THE NEW
PRIME MINIER THE
BRINUSP TOYOU
WOULD.
RW HOURS AGO
WE HAD THAT OR
CKE CAUSED SUCH EP FOR THE
R MAJESTTED FOLLOWING
ED THA UNDER MEDAL
SUPERVISIOTHE QUS COMFORBLAND T
O N E T         FAC
ARE ALNC
LDN,WILL PTH
DU WELL.
THAT IS  THE CONCERN
SO OFTENRES
E QUEEHEALTHISAROLD.
WE KNOW SHE'M
EPISODIC MOBILITY ISSUES AT AST
TH UTEN
BUT RI
RAGE ON IS NEWS AND I'M
NOSURE IF YOU E, BUTPEOPLE ARE R
OUOFM PALACE EVEN THOUGH OF COU
IS A WAITINGER NEW
E DOINE AWAITING SORT OF FURTHE
E PALACE.
MEANTIME, WE'RE
IN FRO
L  PEOPLE.RI MW PRIME MINISTER
TRUSS.
OUBE DEEPLY CONCERNED BY THE NEW
M PALACE.
MY THOUGHTS THOPM ARE WIFAMILY.
AND LIZ TRUSS ONLY
MINISTER SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
E NOT HERE AE MEY A FORMAL APPO.
BUHAT WAS DONE
T WAS ON ADVICE
AND EEAD BEEN
LL
SO T WMBF EVENTS
D SAY THATE T FEW HO
NOTABLY S REALLY TR
COVERED THE QUEEN AND THL
THES
NOT ASAS CONCERNS
T ALTHWONDER WHEN
YOU LOOKTHAL MEMING TO HER BNG N
LEADERS E, NOTES BEING PASS
IFICANCEN THESE ST Reporter: TH
NOTHING TOOR ABOUT.T DOCT
D THFICANT THAT LYY TO
HE
REAL TRIS OR THE QUEEN. IMEOUNC.
SOHIT WE'RE LOOKINAT
QUITE A SERIS
AN24 LOT OS BEING HONEST
PEOPLE LHE.
TALKG G WHATTHE TRAIN WERE
HE GREAT THEY .
D SHE'S ALYSE QUEEN,CERY FEW PPR
S WHHA
IGNIFICANCE IN THEIR
TSNDT IMAGINE GHT OF H THERE >>E
BEMEN  2NS70
WH%  HAVEIRE
LIVETHNA
>> A REIGN O
IL
BRITISH PEOPLE,
COMMAL
AS YOHED FROM
THE EEE AT 21st
HDERE LIFE, WHETHER LO
SHIC DUTY, THAT IS
VERYH  SEEN NO.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT, IS EEN THASTH
ITAS AN  CLE THAT THRND HER THAD
THE FACT THAT HEFATHER S FIRST A
HER RE0%IN THEONER UNFD
THIC HERE HAVE NO OTHER
MOSO PEOPLE WILLERNED BY THI, D
NUM CELEBR
CEL FA
TURNED UP OUT OF RESPECT A
QUEEN.
TH'V THROUGHOUT MYMAZED AT MANY